[Music]
the Golden Age of bodybuilding refers to
the era of al-rastan Egger Franco
Columbu Frank Zane Sergio Oliver all
these awesome characters who had
incredible physiques they're applying
principles and theory and lots of
experience to their training now and
some steroids but they hadn't got to the
point of modern-day bodybuilders we
start to see these gh Gus creeping in
and these overblown physiques that a lot
of people myself included don't like one
of the people who's responsible for much
of this era was Joe Weider he was a
media mogul who talent spotted a lot of
these characters including our
Schwarzenegger he observed the way these
guys were training and took notes and he
collected them in a series that he
called the Joe Weider training
principles this gives us a lot of the
ideas and the methods that we use in
training today whether you're a newbie
in the gym or an advanced athlete
chances are that you've used some of
these principles and there are also some
of these principles that you probably
haven't heard of they're actually really
awesome so hopefully by watching this
video you'll discover some new
approaches to your training and
hopefully you'll also see that
bodybuilding can be functional not only
does it build a setec muscle large
muscle but it also builds power speed
explosiveness just like many of the
functional forms of training that you
see today
it kind of irks me when people say
bodybuilders don't build real muscle or
it's not functional it's not healthy
sure that's true of some bodybuilders
but if you look at these principles
you'll see that bodybuilding is not only
responsible for many of the modern
training programs that we do like today
but also it actually can build a lot of
explosive strength and functional
strength so stay tuned and I'll show you
some of the best Joe Weider training
principles
okay so the principle that most of you
might already be familiar with and
already using your workouts is the
superset a superset is very simply a set
of one exercise followed by a set of
another exercise so instead of resting
you're alternating between different
exercises so we might do curls on the
one hand and then once we can't do
anymore curls and with fatigued then
whilst we rest we might train our
triceps and we'll do tricep kickbacks
and then once we're finished with the
tricep kickbacks of course we would be
doing this with both arms then we head
straight back to the curls and by doing
this the whole workout is much more
intense you save a lot of time and most
people will train with either exercises
focusing on the same muscle group or on
antagonistic muscle groups so the
opposite one so in that case I was doing
biceps and triceps so you're doing a
mechanical drop set in many ways that is
just a superset focusing on the same
muscle group you're doing two different
exercises with minimal rest in between
if we want to do three different
exercises we'd call that a tri set and
if you wanted to do more than three
you'd call that a giant set or a complex
and it's basically means you're just
running the gauntlet on that muscle you
might be doing three four five different
exercises or targeting the same muscle
group with a minimal break in between
then you rest and then you go again and
if you watch my recent video on
metabolic resistance training you'll
know that this can actually be useful as
well for cardio as well as causing
massive muscle damage and signaling a
lot of growth the other thing that a lot
of people might be somewhat familiar
with and maybe used intuitively without
even really knowing what it is is the
forced repetition so a forced repetition
means that you've got to the point of
failure where you can do no more and
then instead of giving up you're just
finding any method you can in order to
carry on to go
further Riyadh
so that's say we can do no more curls
now I could just give up but instead
have a few different options for
continuing so one option is to get an
assist from a training partner so that's
an assisted repetition Here I am
assisting myself with my own hand
something that I am quite good at
another option would be to lower the
weight and there you have another
principle which is the drop set so in a
drop set all you're literally doing is
lowering the weight so that you can
carry on performing repetitions without
stopping if you're a fan of this channel
then you'll know that I'm a massive
advocate of drop sets they're the
bedrock of my own training program I
also highly recommend mechanical drop
sets so a mechanical drop set means
instead of dropping the weight you
instead changing to a slightly easier
exercise that nevertheless focuses on
the same muscle group so that might mean
that you're doing as many isolation
curls as you can as many preacher curls
as you can it's like a weird cooking
program and then once you can't do any
more of those you're at failure you
switch to an easier option which is just
your regular curls
that's a mechanical drop set and we
often use that in bodyweight exercises
so you might do as many press ups as we
can and then drop to our knees into as
many press ups on our knees as we can
another way to go past failure another
principle which is a little bit more
controversial at least among people who
aren't familiar with it it's cheats so
in cheats you're not dropping the weight
and you're not changing exercise but
you're going past failure by ruining
your form so you're making it slightly
easier and that's where the controversy
comes in so let's say we're doing hammer
curls you don't need to see my head
that's my least interesting feature
anyways so as you can see these hammer
curls I'm already starting to fail
so what am I do then is to start
swinging my body to get them up like say
so that's where the controversy comes in
a lot of people say what's the point of
doing it if you're not gonna do it
properly you're not building as much
muscle you're risking injury well first
of all obviously you need to change the
technique used to cheat in such a way
that isn't going to risk damaging your
back or damaging a muscle secondly the
whole point is that you have done as
many as you can already with a good
technique
you're just switching now to a different
technique in order to carry on so the
point is you've reached failure but now
you're continuing to create even more
micro-tears you're continuing to pull
the blood in the area and build up
metabolites to signal growth and you
won't be able to do that if you just
carried on with the correct technique
and if you have a spot around that it
takes a while to change the weights and
actually sheets can be quite a useful
option kind of related to a drop set but
different is the pyramid set so in a
pyramid set oops wrong weight in a
pyramid set you start with your lightest
weight and then you build your way up to
a heavier weight so if you imagine
you're going up a slope up the side
liquid sheet there at the side of a
pyramid and then you come back down
normally we do this with more weights so
you'd be going up adding maybe five
plates at a time and then taking off
five plates at a time and that can be
quite a beast another very interesting
one is the pre exhaust set so a prig
Hall set basically means that your say
you're doing a multi joint exercise what
you're gonna do is to pre exhaust the
target muscle first would you look at
that another dumbbell appeared just
realized I'm doing this video on my
slippers it's not weird but let's say
that we're going to do bench press
before we go on to the bench press we're
going to do tricep extensions or tricep
kickbacks because we want to target the
triceps so now I am doing my tricep
kickbacks
dealing on both sides and then I'm gonna
go straight into my benchpress
and because I've just done the tricep
kickbacks the triceps are going to be
much easier to overload so in theory we
should now be working the triceps harder
than the other muscle groups because the
problem is when you do a compound lift a
multi joint exercise you're targeting
multiple muscle groups and anyone of
those muscle groups can be the first to
give in and fatigue so you might be
doing bench press and your shoulders
might give out before your triceps have
reached that overload stage before
you've caused enough damage in the
triceps by doing the pre-exhaust first
you're getting the triceps to the point
where they're more likely to give in
first so they're getting a really decent
workout before that multi-joint exercise
peak contraction means that you're going
to squeeze the muscle at the peak of the
exercise by contracting it in order to
increase intensity so at the peak of the
bicep curl
you really squeeze the bicep not only
does it increase intensity but it also
strengthens that mind muscle connection
similarly the ISO tension principle says
that you should not completely rest and
relax the muscles in between repetitions
but rather keep them contracted in
between in order to keep the nerves
firing in order to maintain the mind
muscle connection and this is very
similar to the kind of thing that Bruce
Lee recommends for power and performance
it's a good one if you want a more
intense workout is called rest pause
basically it means you're getting to the
end of your set where you can do any
more the point of failure which is a
common topic you'll have noticed but
this time what we're going to do is
we're just going to have a very short
rest a very short pause and then that's
going to allow us to get straight back
into it so it's not full recovery it's
just giving us that tiny reprieve we
need in order to pump out
few extra repetitions that way we can
avoid the lactic acid buildup that gets
the muscle too painful to carry on and
we can go past failure and we can do
more repetitions than we otherwise would
have been able to rest pause a lot of
these principles are all around the idea
of time and attention the longer the
muscle stays tensed during an exercise
the more growth you'll accomplish this
is a great way to get pump and again to
build up metabolites that are going to
add two extra growth during your resting
phase another one that a lot of people
are familiar with is any partial rep so
in a partial rep you just perform part
of the movement so here I'm performing
just the start of the bicep curl and
then I might remember to perform just
the top of the bicep curl the most
famous version of this is 21 where you
do seven of the first half seven at the
top and seven complete sets not only
does that really isolate and focus on
just a portion of the muscle you also
need a lot more muscle control you can't
use momentum you can't allow the muscle
to bounce back up you need to control it
pause it hold it so much more difficult
and just give it a go it's a pretty
intense workout another one that I
absolutely love is the burn set and a
burn set is another form of forced
repetition or way of going past failure
that you can do at the end of a regular
set again I've talked about this before
in a different video but let's say I've
done as many bicep curls as I can
the burns that means I'm just going to
do a partial repetition but that partial
isn't a partial on purpose it's because
that's all I can literally do so I've
reached failure and I'm just doing as
much of the motion as I now can it
absolutely kills you have to listen to
your body so some of these other
advanced techniques by the way don't do
this if you're completely new build up
to it but if you're confident it
absolutely kills it's a fantastic way
it's trying to get away from me it's a
fantastic way of really triggering
growth in that muscle group
so I've talked quite a lot on this
channel before about negatives and about
slowly lowering the weight and how
beneficial that can be not only for size
but also for explosive power and all
sorts of other things well just to prove
to you that body builders know their
stuff this has been going along in
bodybuilding for a long time they just
call it negatives so they'll take a
weight that they can't lift easily on
their own they might use someone to
assist them on the way up and then they
just lower it in a slow and controlled a
manner as possible
this can improve your flexibility it can
improve your explosiveness and it's a
fantastic way to build strength because
you're actually stronger in this
eccentric portion of the movement then
you are in the concentric portion start
to imagine what our knee or Franco
Colomba or frank Zayn's workouts would
look like combining all these different
methods into some kind of really brutal
regime where they're just doing
everything they can to keep on going to
cause micro-tears
and to stimulate growth and this is
actually a principle in itself it's the
intuitive training principle which
basically means or the instinctive
training principle basically means you
just listening to your own body because
when you've been doing this long enough
you start to learn to feel what the
right kind of pain should feel like the
right kind of burn once you can do that
you can just pick from all these
different methods that ran them without
going to the gym with a program and you
can just hit it and you know exactly
when you've done enough and then you can
leave getting to that point is the hard
part and actually using these techniques
will help you to get there quicker you
can also call this electic training and
electric training just means changing
the different variables the speeds the
sets the reps the organization of those
different exercises and by doing this
you're also making those workouts much
more intense and you're hitting all the
different muscle groups in different
ways so what related to this is muscle
confusion muscle confusion basically
says you shouldn't do the same exercise
all the time or your plateau because
you're not using different techniques
you're not using different supportive
muscles you're not building new neural
connections so if you want to keep
growing if you've hit a plateau you need
to mix up by making every workout
different and by using electric training
and intuitive training instinctive
training you're much more likely to be
able to achieve that most confusion
because every time you go in there
you're just looking for that burn you
find it you stick to that you leave when
you're done I mean I say that we take a
lot of Joe Weider principals for granted
and I'm not kidding you even gave us the
sets principle this is just the whole
idea of training with sets of
repetitions is something that we all do
whether you're an advanced body builder
and athlete or just a newb in the gym so
we all have a lot to thank him for I
mean he didn't come up with the idea but
he did put pen to paper there are
millions of people who do bodybuilding
every day and don't know it
certainly if you train in a serious
bodybuilding gym you are a bodybuilder
however if you workout in a health club
or spa whether you use exercise machines
cables or free weights you are also a
bodybuilder so you found this video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please click like down below please
comment on this video let me know what
you thought trying a slightly different
format just like him to mix things up
we'd love to hear your thoughts on it
and any suggestions for future videos if
you'd like to see more like this then
please subscribe to the channel hit the
bell button if you want to be notified
of future videos got lots on the way
more training bodybuilding brain
training gonna be looking at some
legends some inspirational characters
and I'm even going to be doing some book
reviews and gadget reviews in future so
if that all sounds interesting then stay
tuned and I'll see you next time bye for
now